I grew up in a family of social
scientists but I was a weird child who
drew from making sketches of the models
and my mom's Sears catalog to a bedroom
so full of my craft projects that was
like my own personal art gallery I lived
to make I don't think anyone in my
family was surprised when I became an
architect but to be honest with you the
real foundation of the architect I
became was not laid in that bedroom art
gallery but by the conversations around
my family's dinner table there were
stories of how people lived and
connected to one another from the impact
of urban migration on a village in
Zambia to the complex healthcare needs
of the homeless in the streets of San
Francisco now it'd be fair if you're
looking over your seatmate and wondering
what the hell does that have to do with
architecture well all of these stories
involved space and how it did or didn't
accommodate us the fact is we share some
of our deepest connections in physical
space and our stories play out even in
this crazy age of texting and tweeting
in physical space
unfortunately architecture hasn't done a
great job of telling all of our stories
equally too often we see the building of
monuments like the Gherkin or even Trump
Tower
that tell the story of the haves rather
than the have-nots throughout my career
I've actively resisted the practice of
building monuments to certain people's
stories usually white male rich and
bulldozing other people's stories
usually people of color from low-income
communities I've tried to create a
practice that is rooted in elevating the
stories of those who have most often
been silenced that work
it's been a mission in spatial justice
now spatial justice means that we
understand that justice has a geography
and that the equitable distribution of
resources services and access is a basic
human rights so what does spatial
justice look like well I'd like to share
a story with you four years I've been
working in the historically African
American neighborhood of Bayview Hunters
Point in San Francisco on a plot of land
that once held a power plant back in the
90s a community group led by mothers who
lived in the public housing on the hill
above the plant fought for its closure
they won the utility company finally
tore it down clean the soil and capped
most of the site with asphalt so that
the clean soil wouldn't blow away
sounds like a success story right well
not so fast
you see because of various issues like
land entitlements lease agreements etc
the land actually couldn't be
redeveloped for at least five to ten
years what that meant is that this
community that had been living near a
power plant for decades now had thirty
acres of asphalt in their backyard to
put that in context for you thirty acres
is equal to about thirty football fields
now the utility company didn't want to
be the bad guy here
recognizing that they owed the community
they actually put out a call for
designers who proposed temporary uses
for this site hoping to turn it into a
community benefit rather than blight I'm
part of the diverse team and designers
that responded to that call and for the
last four years we've been collaborating
with those mothers and other residents
as well as local organizations and the
utility company we've been experimenting
with all types of events to try and
address issues of spatial justice
everything from job training workshops
to an annual circus to even a beautiful
new shoreline trail in the four years
that we've been operational
over 12,000 people have come and done
something on this site that we hope has
transformed their relationship to it but
lately I'm starting to realize that
events are not enough a few months ago
there was a community meeting in this
neighborhood utility company was finally
ready to talk concretely about long-term
redevelopment that meeting was kind of a
disaster there was a lot of yelling and
anger people asked things like if you're
gonna sell it to the developer wouldn't
they just build luxury condos like
everyone else and where's the city been
why aren't there more jobs and resources
in this neighborhood it was not that our
events had failed to bring joy but in
spite of that there was still pain here
pain from a history of environmental and
justice that left many industrial uses
in this neighborhood leaving residents
living near toxic wastes and literally
there's pain from the fact that
this zip code still has one of the
lowest per capita income highest
unemployment and highest incarceration
rates in a city in which tech giant's
like Twitter Airbnb and uber call home
and those tech companies hmm they've
actually helped to trigger a
gentrification push that is rapidly
redefining this neighborhood both in
terms of identity and population now let
me pause for a moment to talk about junk
ocation I suspect for a lot of us it's
kind of like a dirty word it's become
synonymous with the displacement of poor
residents from their neighborhood by
wealthier newcomers if you've ever been
displaced then you know the agony of
losing a place that held your story and
if you haven't experienced this then I'm
going to ask you to try and imagine your
way into it right now think about what
it would be like to find your favorite
local spot a place where you often went
and hung out with the old-timers or your
friends had vanished and then you get
home and you find that there's a letter
from your land
saying that your rents been doubled the
choice to stay it's not yours to make
you no longer belong in your home and
know that this feeling you're feeling
right now it would be the same
regardless of whether or not the person
who harmed you meant to do so developer
and majora Carter once said to me poor
people don't hate gentrification they
just hate that I really get to hang
around long enough to enjoy its benefits
why is it that we treat culture erasure
and economic displacement as inevitable
we can approach development with an
acknowledgement of paths and justices
find value not only in those new stories
but the old ones too and make a
commitment to build people's capacity to
stay to stay in their homes to stay in
their communities to stay where they
feel whole but to do this we think it
requires looking at those paths and
justices and the pain and grief that is
interwoven into them and as I started to
reflect on my own work I realized that
pain and grief had been recurring themes
I heard it early on in the Bayview
Hunters Point project when a man named
Gerald said we've always been set aside
like an island a no-man's land
I also heard it in Houston when I was
working on a project with day laborers
and as Juan told me stories of being
robbed of his wages many times on the
corner in which he stood every day
during a living to support his family
yes why can't anyone see the sacredness
of this site you know you've seen the
pain too from campaigns around statue
removals in Charlottesville in New
Orleans to towns that have lost their
industrial lifeblood and now dying like
Lorraine Ohio and Bolton England we
often rushed to make these places
thinking that we can ease their pain but
in our boundless desire to do good
to get past all of our mistakes to build
places that hold possibility we often
maintain a blissful ignorance of a
landscape filled with a very long trail
of broken promises and squelch dreams we
are building on top of brokenness is
that any wonder that the foundations
cannot hold holding space for pain and
grief was never part of my job
description as an architect after all
it's not expedient focused on beauty and
he'll even requested by my clients but
I've seen what happens when their space
for pain it can be transformational
returning to her story when we first
started working in the neighborhood one
of the first things we did was go out
and interview the activists who had led
the fight to close a plant we
consistently heard and felt from them a
sense of impending loss neighborhood was
already changing even back then people
were leaving or dying of old age and
with those departures stories were being
lost to those activists no one was going
to know the amazing things that had
happened in this community because to
everyone on the outside
it was the get up at worst a place of
violence at best a blank slate neither
was true of course so my colleagues and
I reached out to StoryCorps and with
their support and that of the utility
company we built a listening booth on
our site and we invited the residents to
come and have their stories recorded for
posterity after a few days of recording
we held a listening party where we
played clips much like what you hear on
NPR every Friday morning that party it
was one of the most amazing community
meetings I've ever been a part of and
part because we didn't just talk about
joy but also pain to stories that I
remember well AJ talked about what it
was like to grow up in the neighborhood
there was always a kid to play with but
he also spoke with sadness
of what it was like to first be stopped
in question by a police officer when he
was 11 gl also talked about the kids and
the ups and downs of the experience of
living in this neighborhood but he also
spoke with pride or some of the
organizations that had sprung up to
provide support and empowerment he
wanted to see more at that by holding
space to first express pain and grief we
were then able to brainstorm ideas for a
site amazing ideas but then became the
seeds of what we did over the next four
years
so why the radically different meeting
now well the pain and grief into woven
into these spaces was not created in a
day healing also takes time after all
who here thinks he could go to therapy
just once and be cured anyone I didn't
think so in retrospect I wish that we
had helped more listening sessions not
just joyful events my works taken me all
over the world and I have yet to set
foot in a place or pain didn't exist and
the potential for healing was absent so
while I've spent my career honing my
skills as an architect I realized that
I'm now also a healer now I suppose this
is a point in the talk where I should be
telling you those five steps to healing
but I don't have the solution yet just
the path that being said there are a few
things I have learned along the way
first
we cannot create cities for everyone
unless we're first willing to listen to
everyone not just about what they hope
to see built in the future but also
about what has been lost or unfulfilled
seconds Healing is not just for those
people for those of us with privilege we
have to have a reckoning with our own
guilt discomfort and complicity as
nonprofit leader and Marx once observed
hurt people hurt people healed people
he'll people and third healing is not
about the erasure pain we often have a
tendency to want to put a clean slate
over a pain much like that asphalt in
the soil and Bayview Hunters Point but
it doesn't work that way Healing is
about acknowledging pain and making
peace with it
one of my favorite quotes says that
healing renews our faith in the process
of becoming I stand here before you as
an architect healer because I'm ready to
see what I can become what my community
and those that I work with can become
and what this country and frankly this
world can become and I was not meant to
take that journey alone I believe that
many of you are unhappy with the way
that things are now believe that it can
be different I believe that you all are
far more resilient than you think
but the first step requires courage the
courage to see each other's pain and to
be willing to stay in the presence of it
even when it gets uncomfortable just
imagine the change that we can make
together if we all committed to that
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]